you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled coded 19 putting together
the pieces of the pandemic this webinar
is part of the ongoing coronavirus
virtual webinar series i'm susie valdez
elaborate and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab routes so
let's get started before we begin I want
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you'd like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen as a
reminder the presentation is educational
and offers free continuing education
credits click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits I now present today's speaker
dr. Rocha nak Hoshi me on a clinical sub
sorry a clinical scientist author and
consultant for a complete biography on
roshan act please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen version
act you can now begin your presentation
presentation welcome hi thank you so
much for that introduction and for the
invitation to join this wonderful
conference I'm really excited to be here
and thank you to the audience I just
want to let you all know the irony is
not lost on me that I am giving you this
presentation as I myself am recovering
from the corona virus so I hope you'll
bear with me if my voice gets all wobbly
sometimes but I hope that's going to
help me get a little more insight into
answering the questions there would all
seem to be having because really there's
so much going on there's so many moving
parts to this pandemic that we're facing
and so let's let's see if we can
pick it from the top and get through
some of these uh get to some of these
issues that we have and and some of the
practical questions and some of the more
scientifically geared questions
this talk is intended for a general
audience so I hope that I can help you
get through whatever confusion that you
may have and provide some scientifically
found information so let's take it from
the top let's see how they all these
pieces fit together and let's see how we
got here and where here is okay so how
did we get here
I'm going to start to tell you the story
of coronavirus so corona virus is a
virus that's endemic to animals
including humans and has been around for
over a thousand years
it is
epidemiologically
cause of
were 10% close to 15% of what we know is
the common cold and it's a
community-acquired upper respiratory
tract infection that we experience
whenever we get coronavirus so the
corona viruses are really a highly
diverse family of viruses that are named
corona virus actually because of the way
that they appear under the microscope
they have these proteins that stick out
of them that are called spike proteins
and as you can see they look like they
have a little crown around the virus and
so the name Corona and corona viruses
are actually called Kobe taken from the
first letters of the corona virus and
then the v4 virus
there are as I said a range of
coronaviruses there are viruses that are
endemic to humans and this is a human
coronavirus there are four that are
pretty well known there in these human
coronaviruses cause software emitting
upper respiratory tract infections the
first two that were discovered in the
1960s are the first two that I'm going
to present and they're important because
they came before we were aware of these
other corona viruses with which we are
all now dealing so the first Crona virus
is called H for human Kobe Mars 22:9 II
and that one's found in humans and bats
it binds to the APN receptor to an Amir
peptide ace and receptor it causes
respiratory symptoms like the common
cold but it can also cause more high
morbidity outcomes like pneumonia or
bronchiolitis which is found in children
under 2 it comes with under the genus of
alpha karna virus and is really a
community acquired transmission it goes
through respiratory droplets and so mine
o mites or any inanimate object that
when contaminated with or exposed to
infectious agents such as you know
pathogenic bacteria or viruses or funghi
can transfer disease to a new host
in other words like your tabletop door
handles things like that that might have
a bug on it the next kind of virus that
we learned up in the 1960s is called h
KO v OC 43 this one is found in humans
in cattle it also causes respiratory
symptoms and both of these are really
what we get when we get the common cold
but this one can also cause some severe
lower respiratory tract infections in
playing pneumonia and this binds to the
n acetyl 9 o acetyl neuraminidase
receptor which is sometimes called 9 and
Ana this is from the genus vana beta
corona virus
and it expresses the h e or hematocrit
or a stream
the first human coronavirus was
discovered in 2004 so as many years
later it is found mostly in children and
immunocompromised individuals they're
more susceptible to the H Kobe and L 63
typically it does trigger things like
upper mild upper respiratory symptoms
and people will have coughs fever
rhinorrhea which it basically runny nose
again what we've seen a common cold but
they you can get more severe lower
respiratory tract involvement like
bronchiolitis but in particular and
mainly in younger children croup there's
a high frequency of croup attributed to
this virus um it was originally thought
that this one binds to the eighth -
protein receptor but it turns out that
the eighth - protein receptor is
actually required for the viral entry
it's not the primary binding site on the
cell surface
rather it's heparin sulfate that serve
as attachment receptors for the hqo BNL
63 this interestingly is the ideological
agent for up to 10 percent of all
respiratory diseases and its origin is
in Palm Civet sand baths but has been in
humans for centuries
the last coronavirus was discovered the
following year in 2005 and similar to
the others in the ways that I've already
described this one is also of the genus
beta coronavirus and vials to the and
Inanna and but it's finally genetically
distinct from the H Colby OC 43 just
above it I put those two vertically
because they're both beta coronaviruses
and the two horizontal are the two that
we've known up until 2002 this one is
phyla genetically distinct and is more
related to the mouse hepatitis virus now
even though there's really four -
microRNA viruses that we know if there's
another one that is very very very rare
I'm just going to throw it in here so
you watch you work hard about it it's
HIV EMC and that was found in 2013
there's only ten known cases and it was
isolated from a few patients with
respiratory and renal disease in the
Middle East it binds the dpp-4 receptor
and there's some thought that it's
actually just a strain of the MERS Cody
it confers up greater than 50% mortality
rate it originated from that but
differently than all the other viruses
that we've discussed and and pretty much
coronaviruses at all this can infect
humans and back and also poor kind cells
so this is really exceptional because
corona viruses show strict host
specificity an awful person a person
transmission is uncommon unlike the
others and it is also the genus data
point of iris
so coronaviruses are RNA viruses Vaart
these viruses contain proteins lipids
and nucleic acids that they
characteristically disassemble after
self entry and then some of their
progeny during replication these RNA
viruses they mutate fast that's a
feature that helps them jump from
species and evade both natural and
medical efforts to kill them influenza
for instance mutates so quickly that we
need a new vaccine for it every year for
example so coronavirus is an RNA virus
of the type that does mutate like this
it's known as an envelope positive-sense
single-stranded RNA virus corona virus
is in general have four structural
proteins known as the s4 spike and you
can see this to the right of your slide
at the very top it says s so for ester
spike there's the e for envelope M for
membrane and for nucleo capsid proteins
these are the four major proteins that
these viruses have the nucleic capsid
protein holds for RNA genome the SE and
M proteins together create what's known
as the viral envelope now what did all
that mean
let's break that all down okay
the explaining this to me once we're
done so the first one that we'll talk
about will be the M protein
morphologically these are the structural
proteins that M are the membrane protein
or the viral matrix protein this is the
protein that's associated with the
envelope it's connecting the capsid to
the viral glycoproteins inserted in the
lipid bilayer in other words it's going
across the lipid bilayer the that's the
envelope that's protecting the RNA and
it's connecting or anchoring the inside
of the virus which is your RNA which is
your genetic material to the rest of the
RNA I'm sorry to the rest of the virus
the N protein actually is inserted in
the lipid bilayer as you can see it's
their green one so I have circled in
green so you can understand weaselly and
it it interacts with the N protein
during assembly because the N protein is
what's covering the RNA
it organizes also into micro domains
it's not really random
so that's the M protein the ER the
envelope protein is a small integral
membrane protein that's involved in
several aspects of the virus's life
cycle such as assembly budding envelope
formation and pathogenesis so it's
really important in the critical aspects
of the virus's life cycle so a corona
virus lacking in a protein to make a
promising vaccine candidate for example
firstly
there we go so despite protein here we
go the s of the spiked protein which is
large protein that we see sticking out
of these viruses they have these sugars
at the end that's why it's called a
glycoprotein very responsible for
allowing the virus to attach to the
membrane of a host cell the
glycoproteins on the surface of the
envelope identify and bind to the
receptor site on the host membrane
they're also part of what gives the
corona of the corona virus the viral
envelope once it is once the spike
protein connects to the host receptor
then the viral envelope can fuse with
the host membrane and that allows the
capture and the viral genome to enter
and infect the host
now these beta
[Music]
coronaviruses they also have unlike some
of the other RNA or other coronaviruses
the beta group they have this cannot
agglutinin esterase which is a
glycoprotein that certain envelope
viruses possessed and they use this as
an invading mechanism if it's SM to be
able to get into host cells better it
helps with the attachment and the
destruction of certain biotic acid
receptors that are found in the host
cell surface so the viruses that possess
these H es they include the influenza C
virus the flu virus and these beta colon
viruses so after that we see that um
those are the external with the
structural proteins on the outside now
going inside the cell we see that
there's this single-stranded RNA with
the arrows the same color pointing to it
and that RNA you can't see it but it's
you look closely you see there's another
color running in there that's really
encapsulated by what's called a nuclear
capsid or than an internal structural
protein this protects the RNA it's a
basic RNA binding protein and it coats
the RNA in this nuclear capsid and that
the nuclear capsid is what interacts
with the end trans membrane protein
during assembly that we talked about
earlier on
so the lipid bilayer envelope the lipid
bilayer envelope is
sorry I miss all the bluebird buyer
envelope right now
well actually sure I will so the lipid
bilayer envelope is what you see in red
it's the thing that all the proteins are
connected or anchored to and it's what
protects the RNA on the inside it
derives from the host cell membrane in
which both the viral glycoproteins and
some of the host proteins are embedded
and it's relatively sensitive to
desiccation he detergent so these
viruses are easier to sterilize the
non-enveloped viruses so we talked about
corona virus and these beta current
viruses before we said that they were
envelope viruses and that's exactly the
thing because I have the envelope
they're also very susceptible yeah they
can you take baths but things like
alcohol that we use in our hand
sanitizer or soap they will disrupt the
envelope and therefore disrupt all the
proteins that are connected to it that
are necessary for the virus to connect
to a house cell and therefore be able to
infect it so the virus can be
inactivated by soap and alcohol and all
these things which would destabilize
it's with the bilayer now inside the
cell we have the single-stranded RNA
which you see as the sort of Manila
colored helical thing and that is called
a single-stranded positive sense RNA and
single-stranded positive sense viral RNA
basically means it's starting from the 5
prime end so it's going in the 5 prime
to 3 prime direction and this is a viral
RNA that can act like messenger RNA
because it can directly be translating
the viral proteins in the host cell and
that's why all that stuff that I just
told you that's why we call this an
envelope Crona viruses are called
envelope because you saw the envelope
the positive sense because it's starting
from the 5-prime single-stranded there's
one strand of RNA and that a
a with this plus SS that's the positive
sense single strand RNA virus so now you
know what that means it's not hard
now these karna viruses they have large
genome which ranges from about 26
I'm sorry 27 to 33 kV and the cold virus
genome encodes for a five-prime
replicate poly protein or one Ain or
form B and that in turn encodes for all
the enzymes that are required for the
viral replication and that includes the
so you see on the left in the blue those
are the off 1a or 1b that start for five
of primeSense will be leading to the
encoding at the three prime and for the
structural proteins the s the e the M
and the N proteins spike envelope
membrane and nucleo capsid protein
now you know more about coronavirus than
you ever wanted to know right here comes
the fun part
now coronaviruses are very interesting
because this because they they can do
what's called a Zilla notic jump viruses
trip these are var this is when viruses
can transmit from animals to humans so
they can go okay viruses can go from
animal to human or human to animal but
with very interesting to us is when it
comes from the animal cause so while
it's in the animal the virus can go
through a series of genetic mutations
and then that allows it to infect and
multiply inside the human now what does
it need to be able to do that to jump
from the animal to the human with this
genetic mutations well it needs access
and ability
access because it needs to be able to
reach the host cell right if it doesn't
reach the host cell can't do anything
it needs ability because once you once
it reaches the hotel the virus's protein
has to recognize and have to bind with
the hotel at the receptor site once it
can get to a hotel and once can find a
receptor that it can bind to then it
goes in that's when we've had the spike
protein connect to the host cell the
receptor side and then now the very on
can go inside the host cell and use the
host cell machinery to replicate its
genetic material and then start the
cycle all over again and back the
infection
now history cross-species transmission
has led to the discovery of novel
viruses in humans in 2002 there was a
discovery in China of an atypical
pneumonia an unknown pathogen that was a
zoonotic pathogens that was causing a
severe respiratory disease in humans
this
this cross-species transmission led to
discovery of a novel coronavirus known
as the well twenty back up for a second
in November of 2002 this hi I'm sorry
this new pneumonia caused a very high
nose or coma transmission which means
that there was a lot of infection to the
you know into the hospital equipment and
through the hospital staff and it was
determined to be caused by a corona
virus that was found naturally in
animals but not in humans that's why it
was a villain otic junk and the ZOA
notic transmission was thought to occur
through a Civic pad which had in turn
got it from a bat so if you look you can
see the bat on the left with the arrow
with the virus going towards the civet
cat but the civet cat can't give it back
to the bat however it can give it to the
human so the research suggests that it
came from the bat but it needed a
reservoir which would be the civet cat
and the civet cat would be handled and
consumed by humans and that's how we'll
be transferred to us so that means that
although the ancestors of this newly
discovered corona virus which is known
as the
Tsarskoe V that that required this
reservoir where it could amplify and
civet cat is that reservoir which allow
for Azula notic transmission to occur
now I just want you to see what the
civet cat looks like it's really cute
these animals end up getting smuggled
into these live
animal markets also known as wet shops
and then they're sold for you know all
kinds of things and that's how we end up
getting the viruses there this
particular one was known to cause a
severe acute respiratory syndrome so the
disease was called SARS and then the
virus because it was from a corona virus
causing the severe acute respiratory
syndrome is so-called czars COBE so that
happened in 2002 if you remember we
talked about the human coronaviruses we
didn't know about anything about corona
viruses as far as infecting humans from
the 1960s until this one occurred in
2002 well then in 2012 another new
corona virus outbreak outbreak was
reported and this was first identified
from a patient in Saudi Arabia although
it's later identified that the first
known case came from a patient in Jordan
in April of the same year that these was
called Middle Eastern respiratory
syndrome and that virus much like SARS
was called nurse Coby because it called
it because it caused the Middle East
respiratory syndrome now that one
although it was named for its effect on
the respiratory system also had an
impact on the enteric system so that
means it caused a lot of GI issues like
diarrhea vomiting and abdominal pain
and while pneumonia and diarrhea were
reported some patients also remain
asymptomatic now the verse coronavirus
is a beta chrono virus that is also
derived from that but they go through
the dromedary camels the dromedary
camels are the reservoir for the murse
Kobe the zone otic transmission is quite
efficient and emerged even though it's
person-to-person transmission is limited
so you've got the big big arrow going
from the infected camels to the humans
but a much smaller animal going to other
humans the transfer to other humans is
typically through close contact such as
like with healthcare workers or with
family close friends and the people who
were infected with the MERS Kolbe they
develop severe respiratory illness
obviously it's a release to respiratory
syndrome and they showed symptoms like a
high fever cough and shortness of breath
sound familiar
2019 in December in Wuhan China there
was again an atypical pneumonia that was
discovered and it was a new corona virus
for a novel coronavirus so it got the
designation 2019 and for novel
coronavirus Kobe and much like the
original SARS it was widely thought and
like MERS it was widely thought to be
coming from us so so there was another
zone otic transmission and along with
other theories about whether or not it
passed or another animal before
infecting humans it was thought that in
fact it was going to come through a
reservoir that is known as the Pangolin
so the current thought is that it might
that the there might be a natural this
beta corona virus might be a natural
Pangolin virus or it may have dumped
from another species in between captor
and death and then that that jumped to
humans so the bat could have given it to
the penguin and the penguin could have
given it to us and just to see what the
penguin looks like and it's actually an
endangered species and these are also
sold that the wet chops or the live
animal markets and the penguin actually
has these scales that you can see that
are bulletproof it really whatever you
set the picture on the right whenever
they're caught they immediately roll up
and they try to protect themselves and
that just makes them very easy for him
and so just pick them up and that's how
they are caught and brought in either
for their scales or for their meat so
and that caused this corner virus 2019
it seems so in January 30th of 2020 the
World Health Organization declared the
2019 2020 coronavirus outbreak as a
public health emergency
of international concern which is a very
high designation and then in February
the international committee on taxonomy
of viruses they announce the name for
the 2019 and Co V or the novel
coronavirus as SARS Kohli - because of
its genetic similarity to the 2003 SARS
Kobe virus but they are not the same
virus also on February 11th the World
Health Organization named the disease
Koba 19 for a corona virus disease 2019
on March 11 the Cova 19 was declared a
pandemic and it has affected nearly
every corner of the earth and
[Music]
you can see here now on this map that is
up to date to yesterday it really has
affected nearly every corner of the
earth it's in pretty much every country
and region these are all confirmed cases
which is really important because
confirmed cases are an underestimate
actually of all the cases that we have
that are actually out there so
here we have a picture I took of what is
the up to date and now it's actually
already increased from the time that I
tried to get to set up two dates
possible for you just a couple of few
hours ago till now these numbers have
actually increased but as you can see
there are close to a million people
worldwide who have contracted the corona
virus and about 200,000 in the United
States with Italy behind it about half
in Spain and China and what's important
is that you can see that there is this
upper trajectory this very strong
increase surge in the number of people
and the speed at which it is being
transmitted while other countries like
for example South Korea have really
flattened the curve as we've said and
are getting it under control now here we
can see the daily you can for the daily
you confirmed cases of kovat 19 so if
you look at the bottom you'll see the
number in the thousands that are being
daily infected in what parts of the
world so if you look at the United
States it gives you a pretty scary
picture of what's going on Canada Brazil
and parts of Europe are Turkey and Iran
are not far behind in the daily number
of people that are getting infected this
is very important because people ask you
know are we really flattening the curve
what does that mean you know but in fact
yep sure it's a it's kind of important
to do and here just to show you a
graphic of how quickly it's gone up from
December of 2019 to April first
yesterday worldwide the daily new
confirmed cases is very clearly on the
rise unfortunately with that comes also
an increase in the total confirmed
deaths
here we have the map of the world again
and you can see what areas of the world
are really
suffering pretty much from this throne
of ours it's not you know something a
lot of people are like oh it's a hoax or
it's not really happening with these are
the numbers and it really is happening
and it really deserves our attention and
our pair how can we take care how is
this being transmitted so wildly like
wildfire throughout the world
well primary modes of transmission are
droplets like from sneezing or coughing
and through direct contact with infected
individuals so contact with contaminated
surfaces and objects that occurs
primarily through people they're in
close contact happens through these
respiratory droplets that are from like
I said the call for the sneeze isn't
those to the range of about one meter
and those are the heavy droplets but the
virus itself can travel up to two meters
or over six feet it's an airborne
transmission that's different from the
drop position because it refers to the
presence of the microbes within the
droplet nuclei that are generally
considered to be part more than 5
micrometer and and so from the
evaporation of the larger droplet or if
the waiting within a dust particle or
whatever so they can remain in the air
for a long period and they can be
transfer these greater to notice greater
distance really double to this meter
it's also very important to keep in mind
that people can be pretty symptomatic or
subclinical or a somatic exhibit and
still be contagious
Oh also get this if you look down a
little hand in the bed if from indirect
contact by contaminated surfaces that's
another possible for being able to get
infected
so there a lot of talk about
how long the systems stay in the air
stay on different objects and the most
reliable source of information that we
have for that was from publications New
England Journal that evaluated the virus
distance of the night Cody - and in that
experiment all generated in a three jet
collision nebulizer and then fed into a
Berg drum they were under controlled
laboratory actions at the high Palpatine
that does not collect normal human cost
condition it's really important to
understand that and the findings of the
the
I'm sorry the virus particle there's no
part of lasting up to three hours
doesn't referring clinically but
actually running experimental II for
this be taken with a grain of salt
nonetheless I just wanted to report
these findings for you we've got the
virus and the source will be true in
this and regulate the SARS and blue ship
the source code e2 and the numbers that
you see are for the ability and for the
vets phone number on the left and the
numbers on the right are the half-life
numbers so in air all on copper those
are the shortest cardboard
it's only a day
the half-life
would be three and a half hours like I
said that some conditions not normal
chance and stainless steel and it lasts
the longest on plastics
so how to prevent this first of all the
stuff you've been hearing a lot nausea
Mitchell distance and the curve and wash
your hands and you know cover your mouth
and tissue cough into your elbow avoid
other people clean your systems like
this
but don't forget the really exciting
this is how we can disrupt the envelope
can we feel of the farce by using things
like alcohol because the presence of the
lobe confers an instability to the virus
and it makes it susceptible to things
like detergent soap or lipid solvents
like alcohol you can clean these service
surfaces with detergent very confident
as long as the alcohol content over 60%
or the envelope and therefore are
preventing the 19 now
the corner viruses can confirm
respiratory diseases and Carrick paddock
and neurological we'll listen debate
about that one
and what does look like when we get
these beta corner viruses or particular
for SARS Coby to the the virus for
but we're now most concerned about so
the symptoms if you look at the top with
common symptoms are fever dry cough and
fatigue in the common symptoms on the
left you've got headaches nasal
congestion sore throat coughing up
sputum not to be confused with the dry
cough shortness of breath and pain in
the muscles or joints chills nausea
vomiting diarrhea and then the severe
cases you have the high fever the
coughing up of blood it's been found
clinically that you the patients have
been those are observed early on to have
syncope or fainting they lose their
appetite not dehydration and persistent
fevers and I can tell you that's all
really true because I just went through
that there's um I was wondering why I
mean I was so dehydrated I was drinking
like a fish but I was just dry all the
time in this exertion hypoxia is no joke
I really didn't know if I could talk
today because when I would even just eat
or talk on the phone because you know
I'm in fighting for so long um I would
get lightheaded I I would become hypoxic
I couldn't breathe right I start getting
shortness of breath and gasping for air
um the biggest concern and I didn't I
didn't end I ended up loading the
hospital actually at the very last
minute when I was people were coming to
take me there because one of the things
that's actually been observed about this
virus is that it goes in ways so you can
have this extreme shortness of breath
you're thinking you can't move which I
experienced also and then you're about
to go to the hospital it takes maybe 40
minutes to an hour or something maybe to
get yourself sorted and whatever to have
your people come and take you or get an
ambulance or whatever it is it's going
on but then you start to feel like you
can breathe again since we're all trying
to lighten the load I right or wrong and
I don't know others have done this as
well then end up avoiding putting the
strain on
health care workers in the hospital
system but for those who are the biggest
concern for those who are not critically
ill if this persistent painful coughed
and it is really painful and really dry
I can tell you so that is the really
common non-critical complaint a lot of
people have this pair exists I could
never say this word in especially now
peroxisome Oh mm sorry dry wheezy
coughing spasms and then that in turn
precipitates the saturation I can tell
you actually now there's I'm talking to
you I am already leaving from oxygen I'm
already becoming mildly hypoxic and I
can feel the effects of it so deep
breath for me this cough is not
addressed with cough syrups or like
albuterol codeine things like that seem
to have very little effect on it okay
now let's look at the percentage of the
population that is experiencing these
symptoms so you can see that 99 percent
of people end up with fever and 70
percent with fatigue 59 percent with a
dry cough etc so those are the most
common ones and what's really important
about this is that really about 81% of
people end up having mild or no symptoms
so they won't even know that they have
the virus or they'll feel like they have
a cold or something is coming on in a
couple days later they'll be fine about
15% of patients end up becoming severe
with 5% being critical in a report from
a Chinese Center for Disease Control and
Prevention the Chinese CDC that include
44,000 and a half confirmed infections
with an estimation of the disease
severity in other words they were able
to really find out what was going on
they this is how they they established
this these original numbers but these
numbers have been echoed
from more patient populations across the
world as it's been you know coming in
and 81% like I said have the the know or
the mild pneumonia or symptoms and then
the ones who were severe that we're
probably going to the hospital they had
the disappear the hypoxia of 50 percent
had a lung involvement that you could
see on imaging within 24 to 48 hours and
then five percent are critical with
respiratory failure shock and multi
organ dysfunction so of that five
percent there's a 2.3 percent fatality
and of course there's no deaths for
those who are non critical right now
what's really important is that up to
30% so of those mild cases up to 30% of
these people can be what are called
silent carriers these are people who
have tested positive for the Kovach 19
but who either show no symptoms or are
showing delayed symptoms and that's
really important when we're talking
about the spread of the virus so and
keep that in mind because
[Music]
even though okay so pneumonia is a
characteristic and it's of this disease
and it's characterized by fever by ack
off by the dyspnea
and with bilateral infiltrates or
intestine mijung and the most frequent
serious clinical manifestation of the
infection is this pneumonia and like
we're saying not everyone is symptomatic
up to thirty percent of the mild cases
are asymptomatic or mildly symptomatic
right but even those who are
asymptomatic can have these objective
clinical abnormalities that means
they're going to end up even though they
seem to be okay they're going to end up
with this classic what's called the
ground glass capacity that's consistent
with a viral pneumonia you can see this
in up to 50% of the asymptomatic cases
so where those errors are or where you
see that what's called that ground glass
opacity and on the right you can see
what the chassis-cab normality should
show normally it would be a bilateral
abnormality which is here sorry
peripheral distribution so typically you
see on the peripheries and it will
involve the lower lobes because it goes
into the alveoli that's where you get
the ACE 2 receptors that the corona
virus connects to remember those spike
proteins that want to find a receptor
well they find the h2 receptor and they
connect there and those are in the
alveoli which are found in the lower
lobes of the lungs and then of course
you've got this typical ground-glass
opacities or patchy shadowing like I
said it can present as much as 50% of
asymptomatic patients which I find
really just wow so
care of yourselves pay attention
now the symptom progression
those who originally start with mild
symptoms can progress over the course of
a week you know this low ink incubation
period normally we're saying the
incubation periods are 1 to 14 days but
they're usually about five or six and
then at around of course
somewhere in that five or six days or in
that incubation period you'll start to
develop some mild symptoms if you're not
in one person category but some people
in that 16% category after about five to
eight days can develop these severe
symptoms and sorry I'm trying and in
some study and like this one they showed
that within five to eight days of the
onset of symptoms for those who were
very severe and also fell into the five
person category they would go and get
the hospital admission within five to
eight days of having like median sorry
of having their symptom onset
so
risk factors then Oh No before we go
into the risk factors let's look at this
this is what I was just explaining to
you but in a graphic form but you can
see that there's a 1 to 14 day duration
for the incubation period that the
average because is 3 to 5 days but it's
really about 5 days or 6 days and during
that time you may or may not have
symptoms and then why I guess it
contained a base where you don't have
symptoms and then after whatever amount
of time when you start to show your own
wild symptoms which is what we saw in
that stepladder graphic you can start to
have the fatigue the fever the dry cough
sore throat runny nose and then the
average time for that about 4 to 7 days
um severe symptoms can last up to six
weeks or more and I can attest for that
I've had this for weeks myself and
especially those who are severe and
going to the hospital who do end up in
the hospital that can really last for a
long time they can be in the hospital
for weeks on with medical support so the
severe symptoms can show up at about
five or eight days is the median time
depending on what study you're looking
at that's after the onset of symptoms
and that shows itself as difficulty
breathing or if it gets really bad you
know that people get confused or they're
not arousal that's because they're not
getting the oxygen then of course the
hospital admissions that can you know
happen within a week and the return to
normal activities depending upon what's
happening hopefully within a week
you're back to being okay now the risk
factors what are the risk factors well
it does affect it's an equal-opportunity
virus it affects can infect men and
women equally but in some cases we find
that more men have died from the virus
than women another risk factor and I'll
get back to that in a second another
risk factor
is age so even though anyone can catch
Kobe 19 and the illness is generally
mild especially for children and young
adults it can become serious with about
1 in 5 people like we said 5% requiring
hospital care and in the studies of
hospital patients with confirmed Covey's
19 the median age range was 49 to 56
years but you can see that the fatality
rate starts to go up and actually double
as we get higher up in the age groups
people who are thought to be at higher
risk of course then for more serious
illness or mortality are the ones who
are over 45 they get hospitalized right
we saw that the median age was for 9 to
56 and then the mortality if it's live
so if we compare those
my country we find that it's more or
less even throughout with some countries
that are involved um this is what you
can look at and since you can come back
and look at this talk at any time you
can freeze on this and look more closely
but by and large you can see that all
the countries are almost identical in
the increase in mortality and a
seriousness of the duties with age now
um here is the share of the population
that is seventy years of age or older so
this is the population breakdown as of
2015 of country and and who have an
elderly population of you know 70 or
over right but if you compare countries
like Italy and Germany they have almost
the same number of elderly in the
population although it Alisa's a bit
higher and yet when you look at the
fatality rate it's almost 12% fatality
for Italy while Germany has a fatality
rate that's ten times lower at about one
point two percent so eight by itself is
not conferring mortality this is really
really important a lot of people are
like oh I'm too young I'm not that old
I'm not going to get it I'm going to be
okay it's this is just for old people
not true there's a tenfold difference
between Germany and Italy of almost the
same number of older people in the
population now if you look at Germany
compared to the u.s. the US has far
lower a much younger population right
and yet again when you compare Italy to
Germany you can see I'm sorry the u.s.
to Germany you can see that the u.s. oh
you can see a fatality rates here but I
can tell you that
as of the time of this the fatality
rates in Germany were about half of what
they were in the US and yet the US has a
much younger population and in the last
days it's gotten much worse that
fatality rate has gone actually much
much higher and instead of being at
about two point four percent has jumped
to five percent and we'll see some of
the reason for why that's been happening
in a minute one of the other so there's
two categories of risk factors one is 8
the other is comorbidities so people who
are immunocompromised or who have
underlying medical conditions like
cardiovascular disease or diabetes or
lung disease hypertension they confer a
higher fatality rate and this is just
one example of it in a confirmed study
that was done in China okay
how do you manage this thing so in all
the the initial management focus of this
is to look for what's going on
early on there has to be early
recognition of what's happening in those
countries that did start to act and did
start to notice for example Taiwan they
start to flatten the curve immediately
and they did much better they also if
you also start to do immediate isolation
so as to break down the transmission and
and of course take infection control
measures
I feel running out of time I'm gonna
have to rush through this sorry so I'm
going to quickly talk about some of the
limited role of glucocorticoids I'll
show the slide so you can come back and
look at them and freeze on them when you
want there is an
Google corticoids the World Health
Organization in the CDC recommends the
group corticoids not be used in patients
with Cove in 19m onea unless there are
other indications like exacerbation of
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease or
something and the reason is that people
wanted to use local corticoids is
because in influenza
I'm sorry that they shouldn't be using
Google corticoids is because in
influenza it actually it's another bit
of corn virus it increased the risk for
mortality in MERS Kobe it delayed the
viral clearance and also in SARS there's
no good evidence for the benefit and
there was persuasive evidence of adverse
short-term and long-term harm also
there's a lot of question about whether
or not we should be taking NSAIDs
ibuprofen and whether or not they have a
negative impact there have been talks
about the negative impact on the disease
outcome outcome but number one it's been
anecdotal because of some clinicians
that suggested that that the NSAIDs
early in the course of the disease may
may have caused a few young patients to
experience a more severe disease just
because of a violation that the basis
for causation and also there was a
theoretical concern that
anti-inflammatory properties of the
NSAIDs could have a negative impact on
the patient's immune response there are
other investigational agents that we can
look at for management there's a number
of investigational agents are being
explored for antiviral treatments for
Kobe 19 and enrollment in clinical
trials should be discussed with you know
patients or the proxies and but there's
a registry of international clinical
trials that you can find it either the
World Health Organization website or
clinical trials.gov there are also
several investigational agents that are
being
Lord for antiviral treatments of kovat
19 as I said now the most important of
these that we should look at quickly is
here the room
Desa fear has several trials underway
I'm sorry I'm gonna just quickly go from
this icon it's been for several
randomised trials they evaluate the
efficacy for moderate or severe covin 19
this is a novel nucleotide analogue that
if activity against severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus to what
we have in vitro and its area and it's
the it's been shown to be effective
against SARS also and MERS Kobe in vitro
and in animal models
so because of that it's really on
everyone's radar and there was a there's
a compassionate use of it for an
investigational new drug application
that was described in a case report of
one of five patients in the u.s. so but
we don't we don't know the clinical
impacts of it this is an unknown there
are a few other investigational agents
which I have listed here
the use of chloroquine Allen has been
included in the guidelines from China's
National Health Commission and was
reportedly associated with reduced
progression of disease and decreased
duration of symptoms but primary data
supporting these claims have not been
published so very quickly these are the
some of the agents that are on our radar
now let's look at comparative measures
there are some variables that we need to
look at which is the reproductive number
the case fatality rate which is the
number of deaths over the divided by the
number of confirmed cases so what we're
calling the fatality rate or the number
of people that are dying is really going
to change based on the number of
confirmed cases and the number of
confirmed cases that we have is
problematic because so many people are
not getting tested and that's the third
thing they are there's a problem with
the testing they're not being tested so
there's talk of the actual number of
cases being up - or more than four times
the number of the confirmed cases so
that plus the health of the healthcare
system or the variables that are really
important for determining what's going
on so very quickly just so you can see
what the reproductive number is it's
just how many people are you going to
give it to you if you have the virus and
the reproductive number or the are not
for SARS Cody 2 is about 2.2 according
to models and as you can see it can very
quickly multiply and this is just to
show you as of March how quickly that
curve goes up now just to give you a
quick comparison SARS 8,000 people 774
deaths case fatality rate was 9.6
percent and it hit 29 countries it was
found in late 2002 by July 2003 it was
gone and it hasn't been reported really
since there's I think one laboratory
confirmed cases 2004 Merce Merce had
2494 confirmed cases with
858 deaths and the 34.4% fatality rate
over one in three people got it died and
it hit 27 countries although 80% of the
cases are reported in the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia where do we stand well here
we are the number that I gave you
earlier today was actually even lower
than the number that I found later when
I did this it's already up to as of a
couple of hours ago or an hour ago 950
thousand people who have it and you can
read the rest of it the case they
tolerate up to 5.1 percent and over 200
countries in the region basically it's
in the whole world um here I've just
made a graph for you to be able to
compare all these different viruses that
are not which is the reproductive rate
reproduction number sorry the others are
their deaths the status of them and etc
just you can check it out on your own
and the comparative measures of these
viruses SARS MERS kovin
these diseases Koba 19 and the flu and
this particular graph also will give you
things like the attack rate which
basically means how many people are
going to get it based on as divided by
how many people are susceptible and
since these are new viruses everyone is
is thought of as acceptable
so how are we going to find out
confirmed cases that happens to
comparative measures of testing so the
swab that has to all the way back in
your throat or your nasal cavity very
quickly I can just tell you that the
tests are easy enough to do every major
hospital I'm sorry every hospital in
every first world country has these
paths the problem is that they're
centralized
and they're slow um this is another
figure to just let you see how quickly
this can be done this is for the ones
who really want to get into it but the
problem is that they're not low violence
so there isn't much testing going on or
for like the US where the CDC didn't
follow the recommendations and then they
had problems with their testing or
whatever so really what we need as we
move forward is um to
sorry really what we need as we move
forward is to be able to manage this
infection somehow intelligently so in
the action of has an absence of having a
vaccine you really need to collect three
different types of data we need to have
an RNA test that's going to detect the
viral RNA after what's called a PCR
polymerase chain reaction amplification
to determine who is active with the
infection and who is actively shedding
the virus yeah we also have to run
serological tests on people who may
already have had it and have existent
antibodies and therefore you know or are
maybe not going to get it again and
that's where number three comes you need
to have a say that determines what the
rate of reinfection may be what is the
reinfection risk if I've already got it
will I be able to get it again or will I
have antibodies to it and and that those
antibodies are going to confer no risk
or low risk for me when we have these
data we can make intelligent decisions
about who to quarantine so that we don't
end up having everybody out of the
workforce indoors socially isolated
which is going to cause economic
problems mental health problems and so
on and so forth so you know
okay I'm just gonna
get over this right now as far as
vaccines there's over 44 vaccines are in
development there are two candidate
vaccines early in phase one trial there
42 that are in preclinical stages and
just remember the Achilles heel of the
SARS there are ways to disrupt this by
by doing something that will prevent the
virus from attaching or blocking it in
any way whether it's through various
method then sorry
speed up and get through this that is
going to disarm the virus or disrupt the
viral envelope or in whatever way keep
the virus from being able to proliferate
and further infect us so there is this
ongoing opinion as we saw earlier that
if you're not poor if you're not elderly
if you're not sick if you're not super
young then this disease has nothing to
do with you but if this disease has
shown us anything it's that we are in
fact not living in a vacuum and that
we're really all connected and what
affects one of us affects all of us
and so I hope that we will be very
conscious of that as we move forward
into our new normal so that's the talk I
hope I helped you understand a little
bit more of what's going on and why it's
important and what's important and how
to manage things better thank you
Thank You Roshan AK for that
formative presentation wow that was very
informative we now start our Q&A portion
of the webinar are you how are you
feeling are you up for answering a few
questions because we have a huge
audience and any questions that have
come in and I know that you can also
email a responses to these great
questions as well
are you up for a couple or maybe do what
what would you like to happen I could
maybe do one or two I am pretty out of
my head yawning I bet and thank you
again for doing this we know that you
are getting this while being sick with a
corona virus okay let me give you give
me a give you a few questions here um
how does the viral outbreak end and does
the viral particles eventually just
disappear so um the viral outbreak did
end in the case of the original size
virus which is very close to this source
code v2 virus they're very very similar
genetically but that one remember when
we talked about management that what you
want to do is to be able to catch this
early on and so in in the case of the
SARS the first SARS virus from the SARS
virus they were able to isolate the
patients also because of the severity of
the diseases more patients were also
hospitalized and so they were able to
isolate the virus the people who had it
and in this way and the transmission for
us it's not going to happen
the cat's already out of the bag um I
feel that absent some kind of
intervention like a vaccine um like
being able to use something that will
confer some kind of ant antibodies to us
against Tsarskoe b2 and before it
mutates and if that confers low or no
risk to us that unless those things
happen this is going to be in
like the food for us hopefully we will
develop a virus for it we have developed
the virus for the flu the flu also has a
reproductive number of 1.3 which is
pretty much half of what we have for
Tsarskoe b2 and about a point one
there's some debate about that case
fatality rate much much lower than what
we've been seeing but again the numbers
that we've been paying for the case
fatality rate I really have to get
chance to get into the variables about
our variables and that's really
important so if you have questions about
that please send them to me the the case
fatality rate that we're seeing for sure
for absolute sure is much much lower
than what is real because it's it's
dependent on the denominator which is
the confirmed cases and we only have a
fraction of the confirmed cases so many
more people have it then we know because
of the lack of appropriate testing and
because of this asymptomatic or sub
clinical cases or what have you so I
think it's going to become endemic it's
not going to just Peter out on its own
viruses don't do that as long as they
can get a host they're going to go and
as long as they can mutate they will so
we really need to be able to find a way
to stop this naturally I'm sorry with
with viruses I'm sorry with vaccines or
so on and so forth as I mentioned
Thank You Rorschach and I just want to
remind audience that you can click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen if you want to
put a question in again we've got about
40 questions any questions that are not
going so today they will be emailed to
you directly from the presenter and
roshni I want you to know that many of
the audience members have written in and
said they hope you feel better thank you
so much it is an amazing of presentation
so I just want to let you know that some
of you have a lot of big fans out there
oh thank you in your elections thank you
for want one more question um if you're
up for it is there a relation between
blood types and the chance of getting
the virus you know I started to read
something about that but there is
nothing that's been that I found that
has been confirmed relating to that so
far so that's going to be the quick and
dirty answer for that at the moment just
leave that because the problem is that
there is so much conjecture and there's
so much unknown this has hit us hard and
fast this is a novel virus that word
novel is really important it means we
don't know we're guessing and the reason
I gave you so much history about SARS
about MERS about coronaviruses about
beta coronaviruses is that you can see
that what works trap elating is based on
what we've known about these viruses and
these diseases that are related so far
so we don't know and we're shooting in
the dark and I don't want to add to the
misinformation the point of giving you
this talk wish to give you whatever I've
given you has been very well researched
on the scientists you know card-carrying
doctor um so I'm not going to add to the
misinformation the conjecture and things
like that so sure and and can you pour
your cover from this or someone wrote
I've read that it can cause a permanent
damage to lung tissue that's correct
um and that's why I was talking about a
great question I'm glad somebody said
that that's the problem with being
asymptomatic
having this pneumonia anyway so what can
happen is and especially for those who
end up in the hospital
is if you end up needing oxygen to the
point where you're on a ventilator that
ventilator is going to push oxygen it's
going to force oxygen into your lungs
which now has food in it as a result of
the infirmity immune response the virus
infection and so when there's fully
that's going to go into your lungs
there's not going to be as much gas
exchange right so we're going to force
air in there and what can happen
remember at the bottom of your lungs as
it were are these air sacs that are now
fully filled in these bare facts are
where the gas exchange occurs and when
your based on on how much air you're
pushing in there you can pop these and
that's it
they're popped and then you can get
fibrosis or scoring of the lung and the
patients who are in the critical but the
one in five that 5% they typically have
been on really high like maxing out the
vent machines so there is very much a
chance that this can happen in
particular for those who are on the
ventilator machines but just in general
you know one has to be careful because
you can develop scar tissues from these
two respiratory diseases
Thank You Rorschach and one final
question and and then again all the
questions that are not answered today
will get answered via email why did the
co vid 19 become a pandemic but the
first SARS outbreak didn't um that goes
back to what I was saying earlier okay
this is a conductor I'm willing to make
so it's because of I can't find our
slide it's because what I was saying
about initial management um it's really
important about it it's really important
to be able to catch these things early
on when China first started to you know
start first hearing the rumblings of
what was going on a country like Taiwan
started paying attention it's a small
country but it managed to really not on
the norm placer to really not have its
number skyrockets like like we've seen
in America they responded immediately
and they say even in December we're
talking with mainland China and finding
out what's going on and paying attention
to this virus and then um by January
they had asked the Chinese got here it
is initial management focus early
recognition how important so and then
they send two people to China to work
with the Chinese doctors to figure out
what's going on got the information back
and immediately started testing this is
that immediate isolation immediately
started testing you know for anybody who
was coming in they closed down their
borders
you know whoever's coming in do they
have a fever you know they they were you
know for a small country they did a ton
of testing it's the same thing that
South Korea eventually started doing
testing testing testing and you drive
through and drive throughs are great
because um you don't go into a room
filled with other people that could give
you kovetz 19 if you don't have it array
is one of the reasons I was staying at
the hospital looks like well I've got
this problem if I don't have crown of
iris want to get it well you know there
he goes
so um so when you can isolate it the
meat when you pay attention early then
you can start to take the measures to
prevent the spread of it also depending
upon what the are not is are not four
stars is higher than the are not four
stars Kobe - yes correctly you see that
we've had the exploding pandemic so that
in need of the isolation and taking
infection control measures can you guys
see that slide that I just put up
I believe a yes they can great so though
those aren't it's not just like
lalalalala that really practically know
something so again going back to Taiwan
I want protected themselves if you go
and look you can see that Taiwan I had
thirty patients that was it
because they were isolating they were
controlling they found their first
patient right away patient one they got
him they controls in the isolated
because they can see who that patient
came in contact with that's what was so
important early on with this weed you
come in contact with what's your history
so we can find those people and we can
isolate them and once you do that then
you keep those people from getting it to
other people and now as the earlier
question was the virus dies out it
doesn't have a host it has nowhere else
to go it's done right so in the first
stars they were able to isolate and that
stopped that one between I think all of
it suppose it's a September or November
of 2002 until July of 2003 that was it
but here the cat is out of the bag
we didn't take kind of seriously we
thought it was on the other side of the
world you know especially in the US etc
etc and so the pandemic was just like a
wildfire that was being fed this virus
had so many young people to munch on and
it just went from person to person and
there you have it
thank you so much Russia knack and did
you have any final comments for the
audience before we close today um yeah I
mean I just first of all want you all to
always take care it's really important
to take care of yourselves and each
other and as you can see you know
especially in the world where we have
become so much more isolated where
loneliness has become an epidemic you
know and here we are even more socially
isolated but strangely connecting more
it's wonderful you know you have to pay
attention to what's going on sort of
been lulled and and been led by the nose
by all the events that have been going
on and the political and the way that we
feel about things because humans are
like to think we make technologically
but we don't and then you know we make
bad choices and then you know we all end
up suffering from it we're all connected
in every way that you can imagine it's a
really small world we've got to take
care of ourselves in each other we got
to pay attention so when things are
happening you know when when we're being
told by for example the World Health
Organization flatten the curve
pay attention isolate blah blah blah
those kinds of things do pay attention
this isn't the conspiracy it's real it's
happening people are dying and it's not
them and not me it's not often them you
know you can get it because you're human
and that's the one thing that we all
share in one case something like a virus
we trade and jump from animals to human
as it does you know we're even connected
to the animals that we're connected to
the earth so you know please everybody
just take care you know take care of
yourself and take care of each other and
value things that's all I was saying
I think you're like a media like
important things right right thank you
again for your time today and I speak on
behalf of everyone we hope you feel
better soon and thank you for this
important research and before we go I
want to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions and questions we did not have
time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by Bertrand ox
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
the end of the year 2020 lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay and we encourage you to share
this email with your colleagues whom
Lea's missed today's live event until
next time you safe everyone bye-bye
you